vamos a hacer otro ejercicio en donde
lancemos algo en el aire y caiga en una
elevación diferente y también vamos a
encontrar algunas otras cosas
interesantes por ejemplo cuál es el
vector velocidad cuando está por dar
contra el suelo tanto su magnitud como
su dirección vamos a dibujar esta
situación en donde voy a lanzar algo
desde el nivel del suelo y lo vamos a
lanzar con un ángulo bastante grande
digamos que lo vamos a lanzar con un
ángulo de 80 grados y van a tener una
velocidad de 30 metros por segundo
esta es la longitud de este vector su
magnitud y vamos a suponer que esto va a
caer aquí en esta elevación y esta
elevación tiene una altura que le vamos
a llamar h y va a ser igual a 10 metros
lo primero que quiero hacer es encontrar
qué tan lejos sobre esta plataforma cayó
el proyectil y probablemente agregue más
información a esto así que desde este
punto de lanzamiento hasta donde inicia
nuestra elevación van a ser 2 metros y
queremos saber qué tan lejos por encima
de esta elevación llega el proyectil de
la misma manera que lo hicimos la vez
anterior vamos a descomponer este vector
en sus elementos horizontal y vertical y
aquí nos vamos a ir un poquito más
rápido porque considero que ustedes ya
están captando de qué se trata esto así
que nuestro componente vertical de la
velocidad va a ser igual a la magnitud
de nuestro vector original que es la
hipotenusa del triángulo va a ser igual
a 30 aquí no voy a escribir las unidades
para que no me ocupan demasiado espacio
y esto ha multiplicado por el seno de 80
grados porque el seno porque si estamos
viendo este elemento vertical este
elemento de aquí este es el lado opuesto
al ángulo por eso es que usamos el seno
que es el que relaciona el lado opuesto
entre la hipotenusa y de una vez veamos
el componente horizontal de nuestra
velocidad de x
que este va a ser igual a 30 nuestra
hipotenusa por el coseno de 80 grados
aquí el componente horizontal es este
lado de aquí que está adyacente al
ángulo y por eso es que usamos cosas
jose no es igual al cateto adyacente
entre la hipotenusa y es por eso que lo
usamos aquí y si consideran que me estoy
faltando algunos pasos en los vídeos
anteriores vimos todo esto con mucho
detalle así que les recomiendo que lo
revisen para que puedan comprender
exactamente de dónde sale esto voy a
remarcar este ángulo para que se note
que es de 80 y mi pregunta es cuánto
tiempo va a estar el proyectil en el
aire
bueno de los vídeos anteriores
recordamos que vimos que el
desplazamiento si queremos encontrar el
tiempo en el aire nuestro desplazamiento
va a ser igual a nuestra velocidad
inicial al menos en el componente
vertical de la velocidad por el cambio
en el tiempo más la aceleración por el
cambio en el tiempo al cuadrado nada más
esta parte entre dos como estamos
hablando aquí del desplazamiento
vertical aquí conocemos nuestra
velocidad inicial que es el componente g
de nuestra velocidad y aquí lo tenemos
así que esta va a ser nuestra velocidad
inicial como nos interesa el tiempo en
el aire el componente vertical de la
velocidad es lo que nos va a dar ese
dato ya que va a haber algún punto
cuando caiga de nuevo al suelo oa esta
elevación ya no va a estar desplazándose
más y así estaremos determinando el
tiempo que estuvo el objeto en el aire
así que conocemos esta velocidad inicial
también conocemos nuestra aceleración
recordemos nuestra convención cuando
estamos trabajando en la dimensión
vertical nuestras cantidades positivas
indican la direc
hacia arriba y las cantidades negativas
indican la dirección hacia abajo así que
esto es menos 9.8 metros por segundo al
cuadrado la aceleración debido a la
fuerza de gravedad que va a estar
actuando en este proyectil y solo nos
falta encontrar el desplazamiento total
y si recordamos que sólo estamos
hablando del componente vertical si
lanzamos el objeto desde aquí a nivel
del suelo verticalmente pues bueno va a
subir y finalmente va a caer el
desplazamiento total final ya una vez
que haya dado contra el suelo el
proyectil va a ser de 10 metros así que
este valor de aquí va a ser igual a 10
metros
para simplificar esto nos queda que
estos 10 metros no voy a escribir las
unidades para ahorrar espacio 10 metros
es igual vamos a encontrar esto usamos
la calculadora y tenemos 30 por el seno
de 80 grados es igual a 29 puntos 54 así
que esto es igual a 29 puntos 54
multiplicado por nuestro cambio en el
tiempo y esto es menos 9.8 dividido
entre 2 así que va a ser menos 4.9
metros por segundo al cuadrado pero sigo
sin escribir las unidades por el cambio
en el tiempo al cuadrado y restamos 10
en ambos lados de esta ecuación para que
quede con el formato tradicional de una
ecuación cuadrática y si le escribo en
el orden correspondiente me queda menos
4.9 del tate
al cuadrado más 29 puntos 54 por delta
te menos 10 todo esto es igual a 0 y
ahora podemos usar la fórmula cuadrática
para encontrar las raíces de esto los
del tate que satisfacen esta ecuación
cuadrática van a ser igual
- b esto es b menos 29 puntos 54 más
menos la raíz cuadrada de b que es 29
puntos 54 al cuadrado de cuadrada menos
4 por a que mía es menos 4.9 por cs es
menos 10 lo escribimos aquí menos 4.9
por menos 10 y los signos de estos dos
se van a cancelar
y todo esto va a estar dividido entre
dos por a que es menos 4.9 y esto es
menos 9.8 y como vimos en el vídeo
anterior para obtener un tiempo positivo
una raíz positiva ya que un tiempo
negativo es como si viajamos en el
tiempo el pasado cosa que pues no es
nada factible aquí vamos a querer un
valor positivo y ya que tenemos un valor
negativo en el denominador vamos a
buscar tener un valor negativo en el
numerador para que ambos signos se
cancelen si tenemos aquí un número
negativo y este le restamos otro número
pues vamos a seguir teniendo un número
negativo así que aquí nos va a interesar
la raíz negativa así que nos podemos
enfocar en restar el radical y ustedes
pueden hacer la prueba de esto por su
cuenta para lograr obtener un número
positivo aquí así que sacamos nuestra
calculadora y hacemos la operación con
el signo negativo del radical vamos a
escribir menos
punto 54 menos la raíz cuadrada de
29 puntos 54 al cuadrado menos 4.9 x
menos 10
esta multiplicación nos va a dar un
número positivo que es 49 por 49 y aquí
debía agregar un paréntesis para
englobar todo lo que abarca nuestra raíz
cuadrada y todo esto de acá me va a dar
el numerador y me da un número negativo
que es lo que estaba buscando si esto lo
divido entre menos 9.8 nos da 5 puntos
66 85 lo redondeamos a 5 puntos 67 esto
es igual a 5 puntos 67 segundos y
ustedes pueden incluir las unidades aquí
para asegurarse de que las unidades al
final son correctas si ustedes hacen un
análisis dimensional verán que esto
funciona así que nuestro tiempo total en
el aire es de 5.67 segundos y esto lo
obtuvimos para ayudarnos a calcular qué
tan lejos va a llegar el proyectil sobre
esta plataforma o sobre esta elevación
bueno aquí tenemos nuestro componente
horizontal de la velocidad que vamos a
multiplicar por el tiempo en el aire el
tiempo total que estuvo en el aire así
que sabemos que nuestros
lanzamiento en la dirección horizontal
es igual a nuestro componente horizontal
de la velocidad suponiendo que esto es
constante que es nuestra velocidad
promedio y esto lo vamos a multiplicar
por el cambio en el tiempo
esto va a ser igual a 30 por coseno de
80 grados por el cambio en el tiempo que
acabamos de encontrar es 5 puntos 67
segundos de hecho lo voy a escribir las
unidades
estos son metros por segundo por segundo
el resultado nos quedará en metros
nuevamente sacamos nuestra calculadora
aquí ya tenemos el tiempo por 30 coseno
de 80 grados y nos da 29 puntos 53
metros así que nuestro desplazamiento
horizontal total desde que se lanzó el
proyectil hasta que dio contra el suelo
es de 29 puntos 53 metros y esto lo debo
de escribir como un vector porque aquí
me interesa la dirección y esa es
nuestro desplazamiento horizontal fue
igual a 29 puntos 53
y hemos pasado bastante tiempo
descomponiendo vectores y aquí lo que me
parece interesante es que veamos con
este problema cómo reconstruir un vector
así que conocemos nuestro desplazamiento
horizontal y también conocemos nuestro
desplazamiento vertical 10 metros
positivos cuál va a ser nuestro
desplazamiento total que involucra en
estos dos componentes vamos a dibujarlo
por acá tenemos un componente horizontal
de desplazamiento cuya magnitud es de 29
puntos 53 metros hacia la derecha
positivo y tenemos un desplazamiento
vertical de 10 metros positivos 10
metros hacia arriba y cuál va a ser
nuestro desplazamiento neto o nuestro
desplazamiento total pues podemos usar
el problema de pitágoras el cuadrado de
la magnitud de nuestro sector
desplazamiento total va a ser igual a la
suma de los cuadrados de estas dos
cantidades vamos a etiquetar este lado
esta es la magnitud de nuestro vector
desplazamiento
así que la magnitud de nuestro sector
desplazamiento al cuadrado va a ser
igual y aquí sólo estoy aplicando el
teorema de pitágoras a esta parte al
cuadrado 10 al cuadrado más este otro
lado también al cuadrado 29.53 al
cuadrado y para obtener el
desplazamiento tenemos que sacar la raíz
cuadrada en ambos lados de esta igualdad
que de hecho lo voy a hacer de una vez
hacia la raíz cuadrada de esto nuestro
desplazamiento o la magnitud del
desplazamiento sacamos la calculadora
para hacer estas operaciones así que la
magnitud de mi desplazamiento va a ser
igual a la raíz cuadrada de 10 al
cuadrado 100 más 29.53 pero este valor
ya lo tengo como respuesta así que voy a
usar esa respuesta y la voy a elevar al
cuadrado y todo esto nos da como un
desplazamiento total 31 punto 17
que lo puedo redondear a 31.18 metros
así que esto es igual a 31.18 metros y
como esto es un vector aquí sólo estamos
viendo la magnitud pero nos falta la
dirección una forma de especificar el
ángulo una forma de especificar la
dirección es indicar el ángulo que forma
el vector con respecto a esta horizontal
llamémosle ángulo teta y aquí podemos
aplicar también nuestras funciones
trigonométricas y de hecho podríamos
usar cualquiera de las funciones
trigonométricas ya que conocemos todos
los lados y como sabemos que el lado
opuesto es 10 y la hipotenusa es 31.18
nos vamos a usar el seno seno es opuesto
entre hipotenusa así que el seno de teta
va a ser igual a 10 entre 31.18 y si
queremos encontrar el ángulo teta
sacamos el inverso en ambos lados y nos
queda que teta
es igual al seno inverso de 10 / 31.18
nuevamente sacamos la calculadora para
encontrar este valor saco el seno
inverso que es lo mismo que el arco seno
o lo que es lo mismo dame el ángulo para
el cual el seno de ese ángulo me de este
valor así que es el seno inverso de 10
entre nuestra respuesta anterior que fue
la magnitud de nuestro desplazamiento o
en este caso nuestra hipotenusa 31.18 y
esto es y la respuesta es 18 puntos 70 o
18 puntos 71 grados esto es igual a 18
puntos 71 grados lo ponemos por acá
igual a 18 puntos 71 grados por encima
de la horizontal y esta es la dirección
de mi vector desplazamiento total y aquí
acabamos de construir un vector tomamos
su componente vertical y horizontal y
pudimos encontrar
héctor completo a su magnitud y su
dirección así que de nuestro proyecto
original su ruta una vez lanzado es algo
más o menos así y acabamos de calcular
su desplazamiento total que va de aquí
hasta donde dio contra el suelo
este de aquí es este que acabamos de
encontrar una magnitud de 31 punto 18
metros con un ángulo por encima de la
horizontal de 18 puntos 71 grados y me
parece recordar que cuando iniciamos
este vídeo yo les estaba preguntando
cuál era el desplazamiento en esta
plataforma de este vector y ahorita lo
que acabamos de encontrar es el
desplazamiento total y el desplazamiento
horizontal así que si queremos conocer
el desplazamiento dentro de esta
plataforma pues vamos a restar estos 2
metros de distancia de aquí acá del
lugar donde fue lanzado el objeto hasta
donde empieza la plataforma lo restamos
del desplazamiento total que es 29.53
así que el desplazamiento aquí en la
plataforma es de 27 puntos 53 metros de
aquí acá 27.53 metros